alors pipoli qu'on va rester un petit
peu dans ça va te faire débattre ça
aussi chez vous et déjà si vous avez un
enfant un garçon ou une fille et qui
veut faire du théâtre du cinéma si dans
votre environnement vous n'avez pas un
producteur un chanteur ou une star
oublié 85% des saisons sont pistonnés
voilà dans toucher diffuser sur TF1
Alexandra Lamy donc a pour la toute
première fois jouer avec sa fille de 24
ans et lors d'une interview on a profité
pour expliquer que sa fille était castée
comme n'importe qui mais qu'en revanche
c'est elle qui a été choisie pas comme
n'importe qui donc déjà est-ce que vous
y croyez où est-ce que vous y croyez pas
à tout ça et est-ce qu'il y a pas de
sujets il y a un sujet ah ben je sais
que je partais un peu dans le vide il y
a un sujet et puis après on débat
[Musique]
jeudi soir TF1 diffusé son téléfilm
touché premier réalisation de la
comédienne Alexandra Lamy une fiction
qui raconte la l'entre-construction de
trois femmes victimes de violences
conjugales
les comédiennes Mélanie Doutey Claudia
Tagbo et Chloé Jouannet qui n'est autre
que la fille unique d'Alexandra Lamy
j'avais peur que voilà il y a cette
relation mère-fille qui prenne le dessus
et en fait bah pas du tout il y en a
déjà fait ses preuves aussi bien sur le
grand que le petit écran ce choix de
casting en a pourtant intrigué certains
une décision qu'Alexandra Lamy assume
elle aurait été nul je leur ai pas prise
je lui aurais pas fait ce cadeau là
parce que c'est horrible c'est pas un
cadeau en fait ça c'est une catastrophe
laura Smet Nicolas Bedot Jude Depardieu
ses enfants de stars ont pourtant fait
carrière en suivant les pas de leurs
parents alors passionné ou pistonné sur
le plateau de TPMP Benjamin Castaldi
avait reconnu qu'il avait toujours été
privilégié grâce à son nom on m'a
souvent posé la question quand j'ai
commencé est-ce que tes pistonné faut
pas dire non évidemment pourtant
certaines célébrités refusent d'admettre
cette idée alors les enfants de stars
sont-ils pistonnés
[Musique]
la question c'est est-ce que ça vous
choque oui ou non d'être pistonné il y
en a beaucoup on a pu mettre aussi
Sophie Davant sa fille travaille les
rédactrice en chef du magazine dans
lequel est Sophie Davant elle Valentine
sled Ilona Smet bien sûr la fille
Nicolas Bedos aussi elle aura beaucoup
de talents mais Nicolas Bedos la
première chronique qu'il avait fait à
l'époque sur France Télévisions
forcément si tu appelles pas bebedo
c'est compliqué Castaldi il en a parlé
et les petits casse-tête dit continuent
Olivier villa bah non on va parler après
parce qu'il y en a qui en revanche à
l'inverse ont toujours toujours refusé
d'être pistonné et on en parlera bah je
veux parler maintenant Olivier villa
c'est le fils par exemple de Patrick
Sébastien quelqu'un de Charron et qui
chante dans des petites guinguettes
partout en province personne sait que
c'est lui il reprend pas la chanson de
son père il galère un peu et voilà c'est
compliqué aussi bon ben sinon les
pistonnés il y en a plein le fils Sardou
le pardon le fils de Dana de d'Alain
Delon d'Alain Delon qui a fait une série
sur TF1 aussi Sardou va à la Sardou
est-ce que ça vous choque ou pas voilà
et que ce soit à ce point est peut-être
que et est-ce que je pousse la question
et je me tais l'interview d'Alex un ami
qui dit je vois pas en quoi c'est
compliqué on l'a casté comme une autre
il se trouve qu'elle était meilleure que
les autres est-ce qu'en revanche là elle
aurait pas mieux fait de se taire
c'est choqué par choqué est-ce que ça va
là choqué par choqué alors c'est oui ou
non
comme d'habitude parce que pas choqué
pourquoi pas choqué parce que déjà c'est
des des jeunes qui ont vécu dans un
univers artistique donc ils sont déjà
prédestinés à être à faire un métier un
peu comme leurs parents parce que voilà
quand on travaille qu'on est fils de de
pilote de Formule 1 mon étant on fait du
kart etc
et puis c'est les pistons ça marche dans
tous les métiers quelqu'un qui travaille
la poste il Pistone son fils pour qu'il
travaille aussi l'été à la poste etc ça
existe dans tous les métiers donc oui
son pistonnés mais pas plus que les
autres les autres Français voilà bah
bien sûr
un tout petit peu d'accord avec ce que
dit Jean-Michel mais par contre ce que
dit Alexandra Lamy c'est juste
scandaleux pour on va rappeler juste on
va attends attends on va juste rappeler
un petit truc on va juste rappeler un
tout petit truc sa fille elle démarre
dans quand elle a 12 ans elle chope un
petit rôle pour lesquelles normalement
tu as des milliers d'enfants
d'adolescents qui sont auditionnés donc
je dis pas qu'elle est mauvaise je dis
juste que l'histoire elle commence comme
ça donc il y a ceux pour qui l'histoire
commence comme ça c'est à dire
facilement et tous les autres donc moi
ça me choque pas dans le sens c'est pas
interdit mais qu'elle vienne pas nous
dire derrière non je l'ai prise parce
qu'elle parce qu'elle est aussi bonne
que les autres et moi je vais te donner
la parole est aussi mais ça juste que
quand tu te présentes à un casting moi
j'en ai fait quelques-uns quand j'étais
plus jeune c'est parfois 4 heures de
queue mais oui dans les couloirs et que
tout d'un coup tu apprends que tu es là
pour un casting acte Belmondo et que tu
vois qu'il y a un mec qui arrive en
voiture qui passe juste devant c'est qui
bah si je Michelle Belmondo c'est pour
le rôle fait 4h30 que tu attends et tu
sais que déjà tu as perdu ça fait chier
quand même
il a grandi avec toutes les vedettes au
monde et raconter comment il avait
galéré
en ce qui concerne là je suis désolé je
suis pas du tout d'accord avec toi
Florian j'ai rien à [ __ ] j'ai pas
d'action dans la maison l'ami mais en
revanche elle a réellement passé le
casting et honnêtement quand tu vois la
fiction elle est absolument
exceptionnelle
n'aurait pas pu avoir ce rôle maintenant
sur le piston effectivement quand tu es
charcuté tu as plus de chance charcuter
qu'un fils comédien et comme j'avais
tout le monde peut-être c'est pas la
même chose
le mec il a un piston aussi il est nul
ça n'ira jamais très loin mais et s'il
est bon et ben ça ira ça ira jusqu'au
bout il fera illusion un peu plus long
zéro zéro zéro 1 % des gens qui en
vivent charcutier boucher machin j'aime
beaucoup ces gens-là postiers mais bon
tu as grandi sur les genoux de de
vedette qui te disent ah bah oui tiens
toi je peux te filmer effectivement
c'est du piston mais qu'est-ce que c'est
honteux logique non mais soyons soyons
honnêtes moi je prends pour exemple
Charlotte Gainsbourg que j'adore mais si
elle ne s'appelait pas Charlotte
Gainsbourg jamais elle aurait été
mannequins jamais
mais jamais elle aurait été mannequin
par contre c'est quand l'enfant fait
exactement le même métier que que son
père ou là ça devient un peu plus
compliqué c'est même un fardeau quand on
voit par exemple le fils de Londres qui
a fait quelques films etc mais qui après
son premier film s'est fait défoncer
parce qu'il se fait toujours comparé à
son papa là ça devient plus un fardeau
mais par contre
vous savez que j'ai eu un petit un petit
accrochage avec louperneau fille tout à
fait au mois de juin je ne veux pas
revenir sur le sujet non c'est une fille
certainement charmante et je vais
simplement dit plutôt que de pleurer sur
les réseaux sociaux bah fais ta vie
normalement il y a plein d'autres trucs
à faire que de faire du réseau social et
de vouloir être connu voilà moi ce que
j'arrive pas à comprendre c'est moi j'ai
quatre enfants j'ai une de mes chic et
dans le public
deux jumelles de 19 ans et un fils de 25
et une fille de 27
plus aucun des quatre on a envie de
faire comme leur père tu m'étonnes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et ce côté on est agrandi sur les genoux
2 etc bah oui moi il y a des gens de la
télé qui venaient à la maison mes
enfants vivaient pas sur les jours ces
gens-là et pardon quand tu vois l'étape
psychologique de certains parce que on
parle des enfants Depardieu par exemple
on rappelle quand même que son fils il
est mort dans des conditions
et dire allô Cyril Hanouna que je te
demande comme un service tu peux le
mettre sur William à midi ou machin
parce qu'ils ont d'autres problèmes
pourquoi pourquoi excuse-moi on revient
comme à l'origine du truc pourquoi il y
a des gens qui font pas des études
normales ou qui font pas au boulot mais
ils ont envie de faire ça
demande Drucker ou Hanouna il en rêve et
c'est une chronique tu prends ton
téléphone tu es un ami machin ou quoi tu
le fais ou je le répète oui je le ferai
ça je le ferai certainement si vous
voulez le faire mais ils ont fait
d'autres choix
c'est aussi ça le problème pardon quand
je vois des enfants d'eux qui sont
totalement déséquilibrés nul à l'école
en déshérence scolaire
excuse-moi bah ouais il nous reste plus
qu'un truc à faire tu es en train de
dire que quelqu'un qui veut faire le
même métier saltimban que son père et
quelqu'un qui a été un peu déséquilibré
dans l'éducation mais dans ces milieux
là c'est pas simple et je trouve dans ta
14 ans ton bus c'est de faire comme papa
et de venir comédien ou tu sais très
bien que toute ta vie tu vas être
malheureux les fils de Londres c'est pas
14 ans
depuis 10 jours on parlera des tendances
de tout ce qui se fait du bien et du mal
bien sûr on aura aussi Bertrand
Descartes parce que la reine est morte
ça ne vous a pas échappé mais pour le
moment on finissez avec ce sondage
incroyable et bien regardez 84 % des
Français dans le milieu des stars sont
pistonnés alors j'ai d'autres chiffres
la politique c'est 35% la littérature
11% notamment envie d'être écrivain la
musique 10% et pour 70% des Français le
piston reste aujourd'hui la plus grande
forme d'injustice alors évidemment il y
avait les pistes 3
et puis bien sûr qu'est-ce que tu disais
non mais je dis que c'est normal de
pistonner son enfant s'il a du talent
par exemple
si je peux l'aider je pense que toutes
les mamans dans le public elles peuvent
aider leurs enfants avoir un job elle le
feront et tous les papas du monde pense
que son fils est un génie non si
l'enfant est nul c'est préjudice c'est
ce qu'elle dit d'ailleurs c'est ce
qu'elle dit Alexandra Lamy elle dit si
elle avait été nulle la pauvre la mette
à l'écran c'est pas lui rendre service
quand on a vu par exemple Lou Doillon
quand elle a fait actrice elle était nul
à chier après elle a trouvé sa voix elle
est devenue chanteuse et elle était
exceptionnelle il y a des enfants qui
vont toujours ramer qui vont toujours
être moins bien que leurs parents par
exemple merci la fille de Romy Schneider
elle a jamais réussi à percer je suis
désolé je trouve pas qu'elle est un
talent de dingue et puis sa mère était
une icône absolue sa mère était trop
puissante comme les Belmondo comme des
belles idées comme les deux lots attends
juste la parole est terminée
lors d'un festival il faut savoir que
c'est son je ne crois pas dire de
bêtises en disant elles sont premiers
c'est son premier film en tant que
réalisatrice c'était très très important
pour elle j'ai vu le film en
avant-première elle n'aurait jamais pris
le risque de mettre sa fille si elle
n'était pas bonne elle a passé un vrai
casting il n'y a pas eu de piston
quand même de le préciser très très bien
toi mais j'étais quoi animatrice du
festival pluriel et elle est venue
présente en film
alors moi une invitation rien mais
personne n'avait qu'une part l'autre
elle le fait
le festival toi moi animé un festival de
quoi ah si j'avais fait sinon j'ai
surtout donné des conférences j'ai des
conférences en économie j'ai donné les
conférences oui bien sûr rappelle covid
sur le retour de la croissance dans les
pays de l'Est